ohio congressman jim jordan right in the
the mix of that swamp out there
congressman thank you very much for
being with us and you heard a little bit
of that of that conversation right we
were concerned about americans your
monologue was great too thank you you
know but this is the truth right we're a
little stunned i think with what's
happened but americans
understand totalitarianism we do reject
it what is your message now being in
washington and with everything we've
seen together what is your message to
the american people as we deal with the
unfolding disaster of the biden
administration
well yeah defend anyone who gets
attacked these people who are running
for school board because they're fed up
with this mark says hate america
ideology called critical race theory
defend those people help those people
help them get elected any elected
official who's fighting back defend
those help those any private citizen who
stands up to the canceled culture mob
make sure you come to their defense if
we all rally around the principles that
make our country special that make that
made us the greatest nation ever if we
all do that we'll be fine and i think
americans are waking up your monologue
was right on target i mean think about
this tammy we had 13 service members
killed we had americans left behind
allies left behind billions of dollars
of equipment and weapons left behind a
border in chaos a economy that's not
growing like it should crime surging in
every major area in our attacks on our
on our first amendment liberties and
it's even worse than that because joe
biden's hiding information from us yeah
remember when when they demanded that
president trump release the transcript
of the phone conversation that he had
with president zielinski why won't joe
biden release the conversation the
transcript of the conversation he had
with president ghani why won't he do
that so the the the double standard and
the hiding information from us just adds
to all the other things they've done
wrong americans are waking up and
they're going to push back and i think
we're going to we're going to reassert
ourselves and take um elect the right
kind of people next year and take back
the house well and we i think we expect
that of course we've already seen that
biden's lies uh has caused people to be
murdered we've lost 13 service members
untold numbers of people now in
afghanistan suffering we're going to be
covering that a little later but if this
is like can we wait this is what's
a struggle here is waiting for this
election but the things we have learned
sir have come from whistleblowers do you
think there needs to be more even even
if from the intelligence community this
is how we've learned a little bit about
the ghani phone call and other aspects
isn't that we aren't going to need more
people to stand up who are already in
the white house and already working in
government well
it would certainly help but i would like
to see the transcript again joe biden
himself demanded that president trump
release it president trump did we found
out the call was fine why won't joe
biden release the transcript of his call
with ghani it looks like he was
pressuring to say something that wasn't
necessarily accurate and we saw what
unfolded over the last few weeks in
afghanistan so release the tren i'd like
to know what adam schiff knew what was
adam schiff doing he's the chair of the
intelligence committee maybe instead of
spending all that time attacking
president trump maybe we'd have been
better prepared to deal with what what
happened in afghanistan i'd like to know
what adam shift knew so yeah it'd be
great if some whistleblowers came
forward but the american people i think
get it they see how this administration
has not done one thing right
everything's that's not where the
american people understand it well it's
it i mean i didn't expect much from them
but to see as bad as it is i think is a
little bit surprising um but i think the
the country the country sees it and some
of these people running for school board
yes they're going to win these races and
that's going to be a good thing we're
going to keep an eye on that and just
remember even a broken clock is right
twice a day so you got to work really
hard to be wrong all the time thank you
sir very much hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else